[Music]
the more I dive into your life you're
you're quickly becoming the most
interesting man alive when they wouldn't
talk to me I was like they must be
hiding something there's a story there
that might be worth telling your lives
are at stake you are doing illegal
things and you have to you know develop
gadgetry and special cameras Etc to you
know pull off what's sort of uh you know
an Oceans 11 type Heist social change
happens when you have 10% of the
population 100% committed to the truth
when you combine the right words the
Right Moving Pictures with the right
music and the right story you have a
recipe for being able to get into a
person's brain and change not just the
way they think but the way they
act if you're fan of great documentaries
and have enjoyed films like the game
changers The Cove or racing Extinction
then this episode is your jam because my
guest today is the multi-talented
director behind those powerful projects
Louie
sooos prior to taking home an Academy
Award for the Cove Louie was one of the
top still photographers in the world
working for National Geographic and he's
currently serving as the executive
director of the oceanic preservation
Society in addition to discussing his
remarkable career as well as his
courageous filmmaking style that often
places his life and that of his crew in
Mortal Peril this conversation covers
his work as an Ardent activist and
environmentalist it's about about
conservation it's about sparking change
challenging societal norms and the power
of Storytelling as this lever for
awareness for positive change and
environmental preservation Louie is
truly the James Bond of film making it's
an honor to know him and it's a double
honor to share his story and Powerful
perspective with you
today I'm extremely proud to inter uce
you to our newest brand partner on check
out their lineup of super comfortable
sleek and durable pieces for yourself at
on.com I mean first of all thank you for
doing this you know I've been looking
forward to this for a long time you're a
hard man to pin down you're constantly
traveling you've got a slate of projects
that you're you know always immersed in
and so you know I'm grateful to be able
to grab your attention for a little bit
here um how do you define for yourself
like what it is that you do well I guess
in the most simplistic terms I'm a
photographer SL filmmaker slw writer um
but I'm really interested in using
art media to scale social change that's
what I'm all about you know you in this
business we're in you know outside of
Hollywood now most people you know most
producers directors it's you know it's
about $10 in a box of popcorn it's about
you know butts and seats and how much
money can you get from the consumer and
I've always looked at the
audience's minds and seats how do you
change your mind because the world's a
screwed up place it always has been to
me and this is my way to try to make it
just incrementally you know uh a little
bit better place I I look at like what I
do
is it's like I'm a a first mate with a
drunken captain and occasionally I get
the controls and why while he's down
sleeping it off I can go nudge it on a
different course M and that's by
hijacking The public's imagination for
something positive to make positive
changes that are scalable and I've been
fortunate to be able to do this with you
know National Geographic and um later on
when I got into films you know fairly
successful documentary career doing the
same thing but that's you know but
ramping it up and you know people always
come to us after they see our films say
that film changed my life and it's well
it's not by accident I think about that
what we do and how can you make almost
every second up there count on the
screen because you have a moment in
silence to communicate much like this
with your audience and they're focused
they're not distracted usually by their
phones or we're watching your film
they're you and if you do a great job
they're not thinking about anything else
if you're doing your job the whole world
disappears for them and they're focused
in on your story and so we're doing
you know Mark Twain once said the
difference between the almost right word
and the right word is the difference
between the lightning bug and the
lightning and you're a writer you can
you understand that when you're you're
sitting there in in the the darkness of
your soul hunting for that word that
sentence and it all comes together you
go ah this is it this is exactly what I
want to say and that gets communicated
with people same thing happens with
photography you're trying to find a
visual language that is relatable and
you know because they're working with
Geographic through you know people that
speak a lot of different languages so
when you combine the right words the
right pictures the Right Moving Pictures
with the right music and the right story
you have a recipe
for being able to get into a person's
brain and change not just the way they
think but the way they act and that's
you know there's a there's a term for it
that the neurologist call it um I'll
think of it in a minute but it's like
neuroplasticity thank you yes and you
know that's they say too it only takes
about 90 minutes to change the way some
not just the way people think but the
way they act and that's about what our
documentaries are that's just by coin
coincidence it's not that you know we
try to make it just that point but
that's usually the the point where you
run out of steam with a documentary The
Bridge from changing how somebody thinks
to changing how they act like that's the
real like trick to unlock right you
might be able to shift their perspective
momentarily but you know short of some
real neuroplastic changes you're going
to snap back into whatever's convenient
or some Behavior pattern that you're
just inured to over time there's a lot
of thought that goes well first of all
there's there's different kinds of
changes right there's like scientific
changes you know um you know the Tony
Saba you know the the futurist um he
shows a wonderful photograph I think
it's on the Easter Parade of 1900 in New
York City looking down Broadway and it's
all
horses except for one car and I had a a
great grandmother on my on my wife's
side that lived in New York she was born
in the 1880s she lived 104 and she
talked about New York being a really
unpleasant place to live with all those
horses you can imagine 300,000 horses
20,000 tons of manure dumped evenly over
the streets and you know every day goes
onto your shoes it gets into your house
and the sidewalks there's flies
everywhere Sailors could smell it six
miles away in New York
City and so when
this one car you can imagine all those
people in that photograph that were
riding the horses looking over at that
crazy guy with the with the with the car
thinking what who would be caught dead
doing that and you know the Easter
Parade of 1913 when Tony say but as his
talk it's completely reversed it's all
cars a single horse yeah and that kind
of transformation happens in about 10
year increments and he said well you
know you think that's like when he gave
that talk that when I first heard it in
about
2010 there was um an environmental he
was talking to a bunch of
environmentalists and I was one of them
and I was like why don't people why
doesn't the world understand the genius
of an electric car at that point I had
one of the first three electric cars in
all of Colorado as was powered by 114
solar panels it was a fully electric
Toyota uh it wasn't a Land Cruiser the
uh like the rav yeah the ra 4 and you
know my license plate said uh V us it
was the opposite of SUV it stood for
vehicle using Sun yeah and did you hang
on to that plate you still have that I
don't I sold it you know but um but I I
remember when Tony gave that talk he was
saying the same thing was happening he
said people aren't programmed for these
these big changes that are coming they
happen really quick and all you look
back at you know the pundits and they're
all saying like you know it's it's it's
not scalable it's not going to happen
and you know when I haded this Toyota
RAV was a 2002 Toyota RAV so I was a
real early
adopter and and I remember thinking like
why don't people get it and Tony said
well it's it happens very quickly most
people can't see it coming and we got a
standing ovation and I just ran into
Tony a couple months ago and he said the
same thing's happening with plant-based
diets there's a you know people say it's
not scalable it is it's totally there
you know this the whole agriculture
industry runs on just a a few percentage
points of profitability you take away
their subsidies or their profitability
this new thing takes over and all of a
sudden the world's Chang Chang mhm and
you know another example he gave is the
you know remember this is a 2010 talk
that he did and he's talking about the
you know cell phones which were just a
few years old at that point he said
remember just a few years ago 2007 we
were hitting the number two key six
times on our flip phone to text to
Capital C yeah it wasn't that long ago
but I think it's also uh a function of
other elements lining up there's a
timing aspect to it too and I think the
electric car is a perfect example of the
point I'd like to illustrate which is
there's a difference between what the
right thing to do is the altruistic
thing the thing that is in you know
everybody's best interest um but it's
another thing altogether when that
product is packaged in a very
aspirational way and so when Elon Musk
comes around and he creates this product
that suddenly everybody desires because
it's better it looks better it performs
better it's cool there's a brand element
that you know gets baked into it um that
changes the Public's perception of this
thing that they had always looked at as
you know kind of this weird outlier
thing that only you know strange people
would have in their driveway exactly I
the economics of it right as well as the
the marketing and the kind of mindset
around it yeah I mean uh I know Lani has
been on your to the race car drivers on
you know you been on this podcast and
she's now on my board and I picked we
had a did a film called racing
Extinction and we had a we we we bought
a I can't remember what it was I think
it was a
2015 oh man had be it was it was a Model
S it was I think it was the one of the
original model S one of the original
model S and it was the first Model S to
have a vegan you know leather seats
anyway it yeah it'll be way before 2015
because in 2012 we were going to be
interviewing Elon Musk in October and I
remember he him giving me a call and
saying can we make make it for uh
December instead and at that point I was
like you know a little bit you know let
down that you know we're not going to do
the interview when I thought we were
going to he said I said sure but why he
said why could go
bankrupt now 10 years later yeah he's
the richest guy in the world you know so
I'm hoping that there's there's changes
coming and there's changes coming quick
and you know it does have there's a
process to it like you're doing it for
the you know the the right reasons and
then when Society gets to about 30 % of
adoption then other people are doing it
just because other people are doing it
so 70% of the population is really
they're followers which is fine but
they're they're not doing it for all the
same reasons they're just doing it
because it's cool but Lani mutter when
she we drove that car off the the Tesla
a lot you know this is remember this is
a woman who is comfortable driving you
know gasoline powered cars at 200 M an
hour at you know Daytona in Talladega
racetracks and we weren't a mile outside
the the lot and she goes or the the
factory and she turns to me and said
every other car on the road just became
a
relic and it took it's taken you know a
good 10 years for it to happen but those
are the same increments that Tony Sab
was talking about yeah yeah yeah for
sure um well I want to I want to talk
about the changes that are happening and
the changes that are needed but I want
to stick to this uh idea that you're
introducing around the power of
Storytelling to to provoke change at
scale and you know I think you represent
you know an interesting Creator in the
space of documentary film making and
when I think about the history of
documentaries it also wasn't that long
ago that documentaries were sort of
considered an art form in which an
objective person would tell a story from
different points of view and there
seemed to
be a premium or an
expectation on this idea of objectivity
right and it wasn't until and maybe
that's not true maybe that's just
apocryphal because everybody's
subjective and everybody who would be
interested enough enough in a subject
matter to make a documentary about it
probably has a point of view that
they're trying to express but in popular
culture it wasn't really until Michael
Moore came around and started making
these mainstream documentaries where he
had a very strong point of view that
that kind of shifted the fulcrum of what
a documentary could be and you're
somebody who goes into these subject
matters and and and and these terrains
very intentional about what you want to
say and the story that you want to tell
to provoke a certain type of of reaction
in the audience yeah I mean I went to
journalism school and that was the the
goal back then right you you tell both
sides of the story like there's only two
sides to a story um but certainly all
the writers I was interested in the
photographers I was interested in all
those authors of those original content
had an opinion it's like you know they
they said something they had something
to say it wasn't you know the facts it's
like you know you can go get the facts I
want to know what you're thinking right
that's the the cool part not just tell
me about like who are the players what
are their interests what are you know
what are their goals what are they
trying to do and then they have somebody
with an opinion it's like okay then I I
can still take an the opposite opinion
but I want to know what they think and
that's quite different than being you
know an objective truth Seeker right and
what I'm trying to do is yeah I I got to
say when we did you know the first film
I worked on was called the cove and I I
went out with that intention like it's
their side of the story when I I went to
Tai Japan where they were killing more
Dolphins than any other place on the
planet I was there with the intention of
not showing what goes on in the Cove I
went to the the mayor of the town and
the city council sat with them for 5
hours the first day and 7 hours the
second day with the the dolphin hunting
Union because I just wanted to get one
person to come on camera and just talk
about what they do and I was going to do
this bigger story about ocean health I
wasn't interested in that but when they
wouldn't talk to me you know after
investing all that time of like you know
why won't you talk to us I was like they
must be hiding something there's a story
there that might be worth telling and I
remember sitting above this park it's
called tsunami Park above the cove and
looking down on it and thinking
like what goes on in there would be
really interesting and I had this like I
can remember this feeling this light
bulb Moment Like if we can sneak in
there and show it that would be exciting
and I just I it all became very
everything came into Focus to me it's
like us getting in to photograph that is
would be so exciting if you could
transer the excitement that I was
feeling to the audience now that's the
story right no matter what happens in
there and you certainly accomplished
that I mean it has this narrative 3x
structure and it operates you've said
this before people have described it as
sort of uh Jason Bourne meets flipper uh
and it's it's it it does function like a
thriller where your lives are at stake
you are doing illegal things there is a
very real threat hanging over you at all
times and and you have to you know
develop gadgetry and special cameras Etc
to you know pull off what's sort of uh
you know an Oceans 11 type Heist to get
this footage to document the atrocities
that are happening you know in that Cove
so maybe explain a little bit about you
know taii and what was going on there
and and what it was that you were you
know kind of pulling covers on yeah well
I mean it all started I was um I mean it
can go back I mean the origin story of
Ops my organization I'll try to get
quickly to rickle Berry in the Cove is
uh my best you don't have to go quickly
okay got okay well um because the story
is the more I dive into your life you're
you're quickly becoming the most
interesting man alive and in case I
forget I want to talk about your
photography career later cuz uh I don't
feel like people uh appreciate that
chapter of your career because it's been
so overshadowed by what you do now but
there's some really amazing stuff there
too yeah I mean I was I was a good
photographer I mean I was I was the
first new photographer National
Geographic hired in more than a decade
this is back in
and you know the first I've been a
champion of lost Co causes even before
that well you were you were winning
photography awards when you were like 14
and 15 you started working you know in
that field and you got a scholarship to
University of Missouri uh and there was
a sponsor to your scholarship oh
Goldfinger yeah the real life Goldfinger
so like the whole Ian Fleming thing that
you know becomes kind of a recurring you
know Motif in your films that seed was
planted when you were very young which I
find fascinating yeah I mean yeah this
it's it's been an interesting trajectory
um I mean I don't know how far you want
to go back but you know that's like you
know when I was a kid just you know
delivering newspapers as like a
12-year-old with wagons you know 75 like
Sunday you know newspapers uphills and
you're you're waiting as a kid at 400 in
the morning on a Sunday morning for for
the the news you know your papers to
come off your batch of papers to come
off the press so you smell the ink you
see the news coming and you you're part
of that delivery system albe it just a
you know like a a newspaper boy but
you're still feel part of that system at
at the very very lowest ranks so
delivering the papers gave me like a
really interesting
background in that little town newspaper
in debuk Iowa they had a a really
cracked team of photographers that were
winning National contests and I thought
this you know the first thing you do is
you see the front page and they have a
bigger picture you know it was like the
photo staff was run by a manag editor
that used to be a photographer so it got
prominence and so that played into that
you know that whole childhood thing so I
started working for that newspaper when
I was 14 that was my first internship
with him I did that for a couple years
and then um but then yeah I mean at
Geographic there was a
famous there was a famous Director of
Photography Bob gilka actually named my
son after him he was like a a father
figure to him to me and I wrote him a
you know back then they took two
internships by portfolio where he gave
him you know sample your work and one by
wining college vti for the year so a
junior year in college I sent a
portfolio and he wrote me a nice a
really nice hand written letter back
saying uh you know kid you know
internships for are for kids that aren't
you know good enough to work you're good
enough to get in the you know in the
industry good luck and I thought oh God
I always wanted to work for National
Geographic my entire life like you know
not that was was my one shot and then uh
so I realized was the one shot I had
left was to win College photographer of
the year and um so I just applied myself
I was actually working here in town at
the LA times as a as an intern and it
just like you know it was just you know
24 seven that's all I wanted to do like
news and sports and that wasn't ego so
much maybe mostly when I was a kid but I
like I just love to shoot you know when
you're working for a newspaper you can
do everything and you know as a
20-year-old kid with or I don't know
maybe 18year old kid with all that
energy you just like you know the
staffers were like Hey kid you got to
take time off it's like you're making us
all look bad but you get away with it
you got the energy but I won that
contest I won like every category that
there was in the college Phar of the
year so gilka had to hire me for the
summer and I ended up doing a black and
white story on the Potter River Basin
which was a an energy part of the a
developing energy cold town area you
know the the pot of River Basin and then
um that was being you know it was form
Ranch Land but now it's
like you know coal property and I you
know that was rated the best story of
the issue I um and I was that was the
that was my internship was was going to
be over and there's this friend of mine
who was laying out the magazine Bill
doth it and he's a little bit older than
me and he had a wicked sense of humor
and we back then Geographic had 1980 had
this relentlessly optimistic Viewpoint
about everything they could make Uganda
look like back then with the civil war
going on looked like a great place to
live and we'd make fun out of the
magazine like they do a story on like a
couple walks Across America you know to
find the real America I know I know I
know the son of those people I know that
issue go ahead we do like bulldozer
Across America and we we we think of all
the you know the pictures that you would
do like the counter narrative yeah
exactly and you know uh he came up with
a the story like our friend the maggot
life goes on inside a corpse you get the
idea and one day we were watching
towards the end of my internship we were
watching uh uh this person you know haul
the trash across the the lunchroom and
he said oh we should do a story about
you know garbage you know and I and
there could be a like somebody looking
you know at the at modern garbage I said
I know this guy Bill rat I just read
about him who was a garbologist he was a
Mayan archaeologist and he's he's looks
at modern garbage to see what people
throw away and study it and and he said
well we could do something on you know
there's this guy Fred Ward who did um
commodity stories for the magazine he
did like gold silver Platinum you know
and so we could do garbage and it was
like a Fred Ward style where you'd
always have like art that was done you
know with and then uh you know he said
we do like garbage art and I said oh I
just remember reading about this colony
of like artists up in Northern
California that were taking art from
garbage and making it into you know C
and so we proposed the story and you
know Geographic took it and then they
hired me but but back then and you know
the idea wasn't just to do a story it's
like in 1980 there wasn't any mandatory
recycling program in all of America
there's one there's one in I think in
Mountain View
California and that to me that was
insane that were throwing away aluminum
and paper and glass and not even a hope
of recycling when the rest of the world
they have you know they are recycling
they're doing you know I called the
story Urban or and so the idea is how do
you take something that's you know
people aren't thinking about and make it
interesting and that story became the
most popular story of that year and so
the geographic ended up hiring me after
it got published well you know to not
after it got published but you know to
to do that story and then I just kept on
doing stories that you know had this
sort of lost right well you were so you
were the youngest ever uh full-time
photographer hired by Nat Geo and also
they hadn't hired a photographer in like
10 years right right so it's not a small
thing um and there was some quote about
like well if this kid can make garbage
look beautiful like we we need to you
know tie him up he's got he's got to
work here but that idea of you know
taking something that people don't think
about out and making them think about it
or turning it into something beautiful I
mean that that is also a recurring kind
of motif in the films like this
sensibility was there from the GetGo
yeah and I can remember think like you
know all my friends were at you know my
colleagues at that that time were think
they were taking stuff that would be
intrinsically interesting you know like
animals like I my mindset back then was
how easy is that you know to to to
photograph something that everybody
wants to see the trick to me was like
how do you take something that nobody
wants to look at and do the reverse of
it make it interesting because they need
to you know we need to look at it and it
just changed the mindset now of course I
know there's a there's a huge amount of
talent and research that goes into
making anything looks look amazing but
back then like you know I wasn't trying
to do stories on Paris or you know these
you know beautiful places on the planet
I was looking at you know the the worst
places and try to make it look
interesting or try to you know find
something into in it that was that made
us think about ourselves but at some
point you you you pivot into portraiture
of like all these um High net worth tech
people right like part of this
information revolution and you start
working for fortune and other
Publications yeah 1997 I I basically uh
called a quits with National Geographic
for a lot of different reasons you can
Google
it uhoh no it was okay it was it was all
right we parted on a good company but
anyway I made this transition to to
working you know shooting covers for
Fortune Magazine which was you know it
might seem like a downgrade after
National Geographic but you know you I
was meeting I've always been interested
in you know innovators and I was meeting
some of the most you know interesting
people in the planet you know Steve Jobs
Bill Gates um Andy Grove you know all
the one point i' photographed you know
seven of the top 10 richest people in
the world and it's not just that they're
rich it's just that all those people are
doing something interesting for for
culture and they've got this other kind
of drive and other kind of mindset but
the person I wanted to meet most back
then well actually when I started
working for Geographic I destroying the
information revolution this was started
researching in 1993 and Jim Clark was
kind of a combination
of of uh probably Elon Musk and Steve
Jobs he was the only person at that
point that had taken three industries
from scratch and made them all worth
over a billion dollars uh silicon
Graphics was the um the first 3D
Graphics engine the way that you could
create you know any on a computer in
real time in 3D but changed Hollywood
changed a lot of Industries it allowed
you to like model your designs right
right yeah and G gaming could be done in
real time uh the day he quit that he
started Netscape the first commercial
internet browser and then he started
WebMD which is a way that revolutionized
the healthcare industry by digitizing it
because most about 75% of the
transactions you do are actually
involved in just the clerical work of
like you know taking those forms and
making him digital he said well you just
do a digital in the first place and
doctors can you know find out the latest
research and he did all that so Fortune
I couldn't photograph him for for
National Geographic he was just way too
busy and then I don't know fast forward
like five or six years when I'm working
for Fortune they said do you want to go
photograph Jim Clark he's built this new
boat over in Amsterdam I said God I
wanted to meet this guy forever and so I
went over there and uh Jim had just
built this boat that you know everything
could be controlled by the computer it
was like a world's largest you know mast
at that point beautiful Sailing Boat you
know he had like a Picasso from the blue
period in the living room he had a you
know Rodan scul Hyperion right is like
the mass was like 200 feet tall or
something like that yeah like uh 192 or
something like that Michael Lewis did a
book on him called the new new thing I
was on that Voyage from Africa to Antiga
um but but the point is like oh when I
went to go meet Jim he was starting a
fourth company called Shutterfly the way
he can take digital prints and make
analog you know prints out of them and
he he wanted to become a a good
photographer said Lou would you teach me
how to be a good photographer I said Jim
I'll teach you how to be a great one if
you teach me how to be a billionaire and
he would he would literally pick me up
on his plane and we'd fly all over the
world and take pictures mostly
underwater and at that point he was
digital and I was like one of the last
people to you know not do Kodak Chrome
because that was the best film out there
and I was like why would you do a seven
or 12 me megapixel camera when you can
shoot still with yeah it wasn't that I
was a snob about it it just it wasn't as
good te wasn't there yet and there was a
medium format technology you have 35
mimer which is kind of like you know
what we used at Geographic what a you
know an amateur would use a professional
amateur would use it too 35mm film but
medium format sensor is better right the
bigger the better and the same has
always been true with film as well for 5
negative is better than a 35mm negative
4x5
in and Jim said why doesn't somebody
build a camera like a good camera for
medium format underwater I said well
it's too expensive well anyway Jim built
one for me he built like the world's
best underwater camera it's still the
best underwater camera ever made and
we'd go around the world and and film
with it and that was our job and I was
like I was hanging out with him going
around the world shooting mostly
underwaters and every time that we went
to a new location I remember he said I'm
going to take you to the best iite I've
ever been to I was in off Papa New
Guinea we fly there his boat's waiting
for us we sail for about a day and a
half I wake up in the morning and
there's these kids looking through the
portal window they were in these little
Dugout canoes you know we're in the
middle of nowhere this is like an alien
spaceship had just come and uh we I
remember we went out in the dingies and
Jim said I'll go down first to make sure
we're in the right spot we we he Dove on
the GPS coordinates he comes back up and
he he's like in tears he said I said
what's what's up he said it's gone it
you know probably Dynamite fishing or a
bleaching event but it was completely
gone and everywhere we had you know we
remember we did this for
about almost 10 years nine years diving
around the world and every time you go
back to a place you can see this
degradation go on there's less fish you
we came up from a dive in the galopagos
and a marine sanctuary and we were
surrounded by illegal fishing boats and
I remember he said something to me like
you know somebody should do something
about this I said well how about you and
I he said what do you mean I said well
use your money in my eye and we'll make
films cuz we had talked about you know
you must have had been thinking about
that prior to him raising it though yeah
and he was you know thinking about it
too he was he was looking at the the
photographs we were doing and I would do
you know i' take a a little um video
camera down I'd make as as a reward as a
kind of a thank you to him I'd make
these little five minute shorts you know
of of our trip and they were pretty good
I really put some time into them and
made him made them feel like your film
school that was my film school well
actually the film School came with so he
decides to bankroll me right
to you know in this this nonprofit
Venture right you know this is his idea
of making me a billionaire he's going to
put me in a non nonprofit business and
we'll do films is he is he living up to
his side of the bargain on this I don't
know well you know I got to say I do
feel like the richest guy in the world
right now cuz you know we can talk about
that later but there's nothing there's
nothing quite like being able to do what
you want to do which he he's allowed me
to do which is try to you know do what
I'm trying to do to change the world at
scale and he allowed me he greased the
way to make that happen now remember now
but like I'm I'm a a you know Pretender
syndrome impostor syndrome right I'm
like I've never made a a film before you
know beyond a five minute little you
know family short you know family film
and I'm thinking God what I'm going to
take my buddy's money and you see when
you're in that world you start to see
friends come and go because they have a
new business Prospect and they're you
know they they don't live up to it and
so I'm thinking oh God I could be one of
those jerks that gets money out of the
the rich friend and then doesn't deliver
I remember we were on a new boat that he
did it was the world's largest private
sailboat is called Athena we're down in
the Caribbean with our families on the
boat and my kid must have been about I
know 9 years old at that point my son
Sam he's playing on the beach with
another kid happens to be Steven Bird's
kids one of his kids and uh Steven comes
over to Jim's boat to me he did jurass
Steven did Jurassic Park with you know
Graphics okay yeah no he used yeah he
used Jim's equipment to make his big
movies right which was the first
breakthrough movie right so they were
already buddies then I would I would
imagine no they never met each other
which they know of each other but people
at that in you know who are orbiting at
that altitude kind of all know each
other yeah well but for the next week we
were hanging out together right you know
Spielberg's family would come over to
the boat and I was always trying to
craft away like to get him alone for a
second so I could say like do you have
any advice for a first-time filmmaker
and when I did he said yeah never make a
movie involving boats or animals and I'm
starting the oceanic preservation
society and you know everything nothing
but that yeah and of course then we you
know the first film we do is the cove
and it's about dolphin hunting and like
how are you going to make that into a
film and the film that Jim and I you
know we set off to make was actually the
second film racing Extinction and the
dolphin hunting was going to be just
part of it it wasn't going to be you
know a whole movie in itself it was only
after we started you know doing this
undercover footage in taii Japan that we
realized that there was a way to talk
about what was going on there in that
film and talk about the oceans this
bigger story that was kind of the aha
moment every athlete I know is going to
tell you that having the right gear is
key to Performance
if what you're wearing is poorly crafted
it's just going to put distance between
you and those goals you've set you owe
it to yourself to invest in the best and
the best is on I'm obsessed with the
cloud Ultra great on the trails and I
just got the new nexgen Cloud Stratus 3
for the road I'm loving those but an
also has this incredible line of
lightweight high performance apparel
that it's just beyond anything I've
previously dawned it's like this second
to none Second Skin I love to rock the
sweat wicking Ultra te and the ultra
shorts which have this pocket right at
the base of the spine that perfectly
anchors your phone no jiggle I'm just so
proud to partner with on and I love
their vision for the future where their
gear is fossil free and engineered for
circularity so check out their amazing
lineup of super comfortable sleek and
durable pieces for yourself at
on.com it's really smart because by
limiting your focus or narrowing your
focus on one specific um situation or
event that allows you to talk about the
broader issues at play creates a
situation in which you can you can drive
that level of emotional engagement and
get people to really care when it's
difficult to do that when you're at
10,000 fet and you're you know shooting
statistics at them and you're kind of
toggling back and forth from all
different places all over the world it's
that idea of like the world stops when
you know there's one girl at the bottom
of a well somewhere in you know I don't
know some remote Village uh but we you
know are challenged to even blink when
we see a headline about a genocide
somewhere that's far away from where we
live yeah Kristoff wasn't it you know
from the writer for the New York Times
he said that like you know if you could
you know get the audience to care about
one person then at the end of it you
know is always saying but there's three
million just like her yeah you know that
was that's the key isn't it to find that
emotional hook and then you're still
bringing in those big picture 20 you
know 10,000 foot views you know as the
stakes you know in the Cove you know
it's about what they're doing which is
horrible but it's also in that film we
talk about over fishing because the
Fisher and taii they rationalize that
they're killing the Dolphins because
they're eating all their fishh what it's
not you know the dolphins eating their
all fish it's you know the 145 million
people in Japan that eat almost nothing
but and all the Americans and you know
eight half billion people on the or 8
billion people on the planet now a lot
of them are pescatarians and you know
this these are wild animals you know
it's like I believe those fishermen did
believe that though I do too I I think
but or they had to believe it in order
to actually perpetrate those atrocities
yeah yeah I mean we all do that right we
all rationalize a lot of our um bad
behavior because of whatever I need to
make a living you know the social good I
I remember this is a funny story like we
were making the cove and I was going
down to the IWC the international
wailing commission meeting down in
Chile and I wanted to
interview the director of the the IWC
for Japan and his name was Akira
nakami and this is why I know that if
there is a God he has a he she they have
a good sense of humor so I'm on a flight
from Dallas down to Chile and they're
holding the plane and the plane is
completely filled up I can't even sit
with my crew and but there's one seat
empty next to me and the last person to
ex exit the door we've been waiting for
him to get into another plane is Zakir
nakami and he comes down he sits down
right next to me and I'm looking at my
crew like do you have any they're
looking at like oh my God like of of all
the you know all the Gin joints in all
the world you know and I waited till the
plane took off because I don't want him
to be able to switch with maybe somebody
that you know from his own team was on
the fil on the plane and then when we
had dinner served I turned to him I said
do you have any idea who I am he goes no
he says I know who you are I want to
show you a film and we had like a
17-minute cut of the Cove that was like
a Sizzle
reel and this goes back to okay here's
the guy that's responsible for Dolphin
quotas and whale cotas in Japan uh about
a week or two before they were just
caught illegally fish fishing blue fin
to the tune of you know th hundreds of
tons of illegally caught blue fin tuna
and so I had this opportunity to ask
him you know every anything I wanted to
ask him he's right there where's he
going to go he's a captive audience say
you're you're the guy that's now back
then remember this if you haven't seen
the Cove you know part of the premise is
that dolphin meat is all toxic that's
where we we win it's not just a matter
of you know there's are beautiful
sensient animals what are you doing
killing them their meats toxic and they
were Force feeding at the school kids in
Japan by force feeding you know be you
had to eat everything on your plate when
you were a kid you couldn't bring in
they make you clean your plate and you
couldn't bring your own lunch right like
you had to eat the mandated lunch it
dolphin meat it was poison I mean
literally it was poison it had anywhere
to from 5 to 5,000 times more Mercury if
it was a fish because it's a m
so um they got by with this loophole and
I said to Kira nakami I said you're the
guy that's responsible for they had a
plan to school to put Dolph meat on
school lunch programs all over Japan
right right before this happened and I
said you're
giving dolphin meat laced with Mercury
that's extremely dilit terious effects
to especially young kids I said how do
you reconcile with what you're doing you
supply I'm charged of food security not
food
safety going back to your thing like we
all make rational ctive dissonance that
you have to engage with to just get up
in the morning and do your job but that
that's the is that the same guy in the
co with like the grayish longer longer
hair no that was his boss no Shi that
was worked underneath
Aira yeah and that was it end of end of
discussion that well yeah I mean he
agreed to once we got to to well and his
argument would be food security is an
important issue in Japan because it's an
island nation they don't have you know
grazing pasture lands like we have Etc
and it is a challenge to make sure that
the however many hundred million plus
people that live in Japan have adequate
uh access to food yeah you could have
written his Playbook that's exactly what
he told me he said he said he said we
have 145 million people in Japan about
the same size is your California only
177% of our land is habitable to put our
you know homes and and businesses we
have to look to the Sea for our our food
that's why we're illegally fishing tuna
that's why we're you know looking to you
know to eat whales when the rest of the
the world is and just Brazen with the
fact that they're transgressing all of
these
laws yeah yeah so that's you know there
was a rationale for
everything it is so challenging I I
rewatched The Cove last night to to
watch those
scenes um where you get these cameras
into this Cove which is really you know
basically they they Corral these
dolphins for people who haven't seen the
movie into this particular Cove they do
that by banging on pipes and dolphins
being very um sensitive to sound out of
fear uh you know they they sort of push
them into this Cove and then they rope
it off with Nets and then they just
Slaughter most of them and they pick out
a few that they they then sell to the um
you know inter the sort of marine
entertainment complex correct and those
those those animals fetch a pretty price
and the rest are used for food exactly
and they make most I think a dead
dolphin you know on the meat counter
sells for about $600 or used to $600 a
piece and a trained dolphin can sell for
150,000 maybe a quart of a mill
now and so that's the economics of it is
a very small town and that really plays
into you know makes a lot of money for
that industry for you know for that town
you know by serving that industry so
those those Dolphins will go to the
Middle East mostly and China and Japan I
think Japan had at that time over 50
dolphinariums MH the film ends up
getting criticized for uh you know kind
of taking shots at at at like their
culture right like this is is our
culture how dare you you Slaughter pigs
and cows Etc um also this food security
issue sort of is used or deployed as a
as a you know Counterpoint to the issues
that you're raising um but what's
interesting is is what you realize is
that most people in Japan don't know
this is going on people in Tai don't
even know what going on and taii is this
town that's like draped in all this
iconography around whales and dolphins
like they're celebrating these beautiful
animals but right underneath their feet
yeah like this is what's actually
happening so Japan itself the the normal
citizen in Japan appeared to be just as
surprised as any audience member who who
would watch your film yeah me we got
that early on like you know culinary
imperialism they call it and you know
there's a certain amount of Truth to
that but you know if your kids were
being force-fed toxic meat or toxic
vegetables at your School wouldn't you
be thrilled that anybody from any
country would come in and tell you
what's what when your country is
covering it up you know yeah that's why
the Mercury argument is is the strongest
one in terms of you know kind of
overriding everything else yeah Rick and
I Rick Rick oberry is the you know the
protagonist of the film he's the guy who
captured and trained the five female
dolphins that collectively played the
part of flipper for The Flipper TV
series we had a you know kind of a a
running thing between us whenever we
talk to the Japanese media we tried to
use the word mercury in every sentence
so they couldn't cut it out they'd say
well like oh what about cows pigs and
chickens I say well your our chickens
had that much mercury you know you know
we'd always like try to our creative way
to try to bring it back to Mercury
because that was their Achilles heel
they couldn't you couldn't argue Mercury
is good Mercury is good for kids you
know they had yeah that you know the
first big industrial accident in the
world that was announced was you know
minamata bay you
know minamata disease it's not a disease
they weren't this company called chisa
minamata was
intentionally dumping mercury into the
bay and infecting tens of thousands
hundreds of thousands of people and that
got discovered in the 1950s and you know
so Mercury po they were found to be
guilty M and there all these birth
defects pregnant women ingesting this
and yeah I remember there's a there was
a researcher I think from America that
would study mercury poisoning here in
America and he went over to Japan
remember this is post World War II and
that part of Japan you couldn't easily
get to I don't think there was roads
back then so he got there by boat and he
got to this this Bay and everybody
looked like they had murky poisoning
it's like can imagine it's really looks
like you're deformed you know all sorts
of birth defects hits the older people
too but the kids have the most dilus
effects and so that's how it was
discovered the government was helping
this company try to cover it up they
were found guilty so Mercury is a
trigger word right so in Japan everybody
knows about this yeah and they're
sensitive to it and then on a personal
level I mean this is part of your own
kind of Awakening your own mercury
poisoning yeah well the the I
interviewed the Doctor Who developed a
test to find out how much damages the
people that were affected are
do and he developed something called a
two-point noal test which is like a
protractor with two points on it and
depending on the distance you can feel
the two points on a fingertip he could
pretty accurately tell you how much
mercury poison you had then he showed me
the corollary of what that would because
he had the brains of people after they
died they would you know take their
brains out and he had brain slices and
it looked like swiss cheese it would
literally develop holes in your brain
wow and I remember asking him was like
what's what's that mean to have this
disease and he slow he said it slowly
erases what it means to be human it
takes away your senses it takes away
your memory your sense of touch your
your sense of hearing you know all your
senses start to go and then when you
know so this this is in my mind now at
that time I was a pescatarian I ate fish
and I was I was delighted to be in Japan
because I could eat fish you know
breakfast lunch and dinner I wasn't like
you know when I was working for a
Fortune Magazine I did a a story on the
biggest independently owned slaughter
houses in America and one was in
Oklahoma and it was so big they had
their own slaughterous like 500 cows a
day would go through there and I spent
several hours
there and one of these cows if you ever
know about the process you know there's
there's a reason why they say if
slaughter houses had Glass Walls be be
you know against the egg EG laws yeah
and they put What's called the captive
bolt to the the head of a cow and that's
supposed to kill him instantly I
remember this one cow was they they put
him they chain him up by his back heels
and they rip off the hide and then they
start to slowly as it goes around
through these it's like it's like the
reverse of a car manufacturing plant
they're de assembling the cow you know
that stations instead of putting it
together remember this cow comes by at
the first turn and it's turning its head
it's looking at me hang upside down and
realized it was still conscious it was
still alive and still alive yeah it must
with a bolt in its head but not dead
like a old country No Country for Old
Men exactly yeah yeah and it was it was
horrifying and I thought I can't be
party of this industry but I ate fish I
thought well I'll have to eat you have
to eat fish to be you know human you
have to have animal products I ate fish
I thought well they're going to be less
sensient intelligent and so I was a
pescatarian so this is 1986 and this is
when I'm doing the Cove would have been
like 2007 and something like that 2008
and I remember I was eating a lot of
fish back then I thought well I should
have one of the last scenes we do in the
movie is we take the deputy minister of
Fisheries hiim more Nuki and we take a
hair sample because he he can do blood
samples you can do hair samples to
figure out how much mercury some
somebody has so we clipped his hair you
know with with with his permission and I
sent it in he took it into his lab and
he I didn't tell him whose samples they
were but he said he he said hii sample
was like eight times higher than what's
considered too high wow
and uh he said he said who's this other
sample I said it's mine he says well
yours is 44 Times Higher oh and having
seen what it does to the brain of
somebody with mercury poisoning I just a
shock went through me like and you're in
the middle of making this movie about
this very subject yeah and I'm thinking
what and then also what am I going to
eat yeah you know like I I would imagine
it's probably like what the Japanese
would have thought what do you what are
you going to eat if you can't eat fish
and I remember
so I I remember we I had to cut out you
know eating fish because it wasn't it
wasn't a joke it wasn't just like
something I do later because it to me it
was real palpable to to see the brain
slices and say this could be done be
going on with mine you were asymptomatic
though I had I had symptoms I had like a
short-term memory loss I had this pain
in my shoulder that was persistent would
never go away I thought it was like from
lifting C cameras or something and when
I stopped eting fish it has a half life
in your body Mercury of about 70 to 90
days and after a couple months it went
away and I was like oh wow this is
serious and I was here for the Academy
Awards we were doing this this runup you
know the all the media push and I
remember sitting with uh Rebecca Meek
she was a designer a vegan you know
clothing designer she was like a friend
of this guy that I that I met and I
wasn't she was I was at happened to be
at at lunch with her and she starts
ordering off the menu working with the
waiter to try to you make a a dish and I
was like are you vegetarian she goes no
I'm vegan I go what do you eat she goes
everything else uhhuh and she you know
she explained that you know that's where
do you think the animals get their
protein where do they get their
nutrients from and when her dish came it
looked better than anything that we all
had on our plates and um that was it I
think that was it that was your your
lightning bold yaha moment yeah of like
okay you don't have to do this
interesting it's interesting that that
happened in the wake of making that
movie and not prior to it like you had
your own Journey with all of this too
long it's too stupid you know there's
there's a line I think it was one of the
best lines in the movie from Rick oerry
he said I was as ignorant as I could be
for as long as I could be yeah about
what he was talking about when he was
training dolphins that guy's amazing um
you know I I'm old enough to remember
flipper and I loved flipper I had a uh
my favorite thing when I was a kid I had
a brass uh belt buckle that was a
dolphin like I was it's still my spirit
animal like I just love dolphins and his
story just haunts me of training those
five Dolphins to be flipper for that
show
um and you know believing that he was
what he was doing was ethically sound at
the time and then when the show's over
the Dolphins get um you know sent away
to these uh were they were they they
weren't they weren't going to like
SeaWorld right but they were going to
tanks somewhere Miami sarum yeah oh oh
that's where they were and then he goes
and he visits Katherine was that the
name of the the main one Kathy and Kathy
pops up and they lock eyes Kathy looks
at him takes a breath and goes down to
the bottom of the tank and decides not
to take another breath and dolphins
being animals that that don't have an
involuntary kind of breath impulse it's
a choice
basically commits
suicide which is
just I can't stop thinking about that it
gives me CH still and whenever I see
that part of the movie and and it's like
it's those kind of moments like if
you're doing a big film let's say on
ocean Health you don't have that I mean
that feeling that you have right now
that hopefully the audience feels like
this animal committing suicide swam into
his arms looked at him in the eyes and
swam out the bottom of the tank
committed suicide you know you can
imagine
what it would be like to be that you
know that animal can imagine
like I think everybody can imagine what
it would be like to be alone without
your own species in a a miserable tank
you know and all you know at that moment
you're with Rick you'll you want him to
succeed you're you know he becomes a
hero right then and those
transformational moments you just can't
get when you're just doing a
normal documentary let's say in the in
the Nova way you know I I don't want to
criticize Nova I watch all those you
know novas I watch you know the Marvel
films the the the Attenborough sort of
style of of documentary nature
storytelling yeah and aten Boro for a
long time I mean I watched those
documentaries too but you know and I've
been to those places that he's talking
about and in those Oasis
those ever diminishing Oasis is where
you can see the the Sardine run you can
see the the the migration they're still
out there albeit now it's going through
more urban areas and it's you can still
make it if you frame it you can make it
look like they're still there and to the
audience you're doing a little bit of a
disservice by saying the world is you
know isn't changed it's a bit like
greenwashing because it makes us feel
better about what's happening when we
see that beauty and then we're less
likely to take
action yeah I mean that's that's my
feeling I mean I again I love watching
you know all those those Wildlife
documentaries I I love the the courage
that it takes to be embedded with these
animals and and see them on their own
terms but at the same time you know I'm
in my mind I'm going what can I do to
try to holdt that that that change you
know that's
uh you know there's there's a word for
it where they you know you have a these
diminishing
ecosystems that you know in every
generation adapts to the successive
demise of the one created before it a
shifting Baseline and you know is is it
just Pana to say hey well this is just
inevitable we're we're we're destined as
human beings to oversee the you know the
demise of the world that's just the way
it is or or can you be part of this
mechanism that can create a change is
there a scientific you
know reason why everybody will
eventually go vegan or um adapt to a
more compassionate world and I I think
there is I think there is a there's a
lot of hope there's a lot of signals I'm
getting that we can go that way and I
think films can Edge us towards that
eventuality when we did that film they
were killing 23,000 dolphins and
porposes every year in Japan for human
consumption in the last year I looked it
was like two years ago I think they
killed 1610 so it's down over 93% since
we started that film so
films are very very powerful weapons for
for social change and that's why I do
what we're doing we had you know rickle
telling rickle Berry's story had a
profound effect on that industry they're
still capturing them for the
entertainment industry there's still you
know there's C countries that are you
know have been Banning it it seems to it
goes you you said it here before that
it's you know progress is never a
straight line it's it's messy life is
messy there's ups and downs but you know
I I I hopeful enough about you know
where we're going to to feel like we can
be part of the mechanism that pushes us
us towards a better a better Society
yeah i' I've heard your films described
I don't know whether this is your term
or not um as Weapons of Mass instruction
Construction Construction instruction
isn't it Weapons of Mass instruction
yeah well it's a destruction
construction destruction in construction
um which I love it's like how can I
deploy how can I weaponize storytelling
for a specific aim and do it in a
compelling way and and you know that's
that's sort of you know your approach to
these films and they are impactful I
mean the Cove I mean certainly they're
not serving dolphin meat for school
lunch anymore in Japan and I know you
know you put your life and the life of
your crew in Peril to make that movie
and that was not easy and you still can
you go you can't go back to Japan can
you can you go back have you been back I
can go back go back I just can't get
back
out um and there was a period of time
where it was unclear whether the movie
was even going to screen in Japan right
it has since yeah well what happened
was oh God I wish there was a a famous I
think it was SP one of the famous
Spanish directors I believe was doing uh
the Tokyo film International Film
Festival I yeah and he said if uh if you
don't show The Cove because they're
doing a a Green carpet instead of a
grand carpet they trying to make like a
like a green he says if you don't show
The Cove I'm going to quit and there's
going to be an international protest so
I went and so I went over to Japan with
our you know our my attorney and we get
off the plane and like I'm not talking
about like in the terminal I'm talking
about on the gang way like the first
like when the you know that that
passageway from you know the plane
there's presses lined there taking
pictures of me getting off the plane and
they're saying you know asking me
questions like there all people behind
me I'm thinking like oh I am going to
get arrested this is you know this is
not going to be pleasant and so we were
escort in police protection we you know
I walked the red carpet but I was
totally alone there wasn't a single
person there they cleared the place out
you no they cleared it out they made it
so that it was going to be you know
they're going to make a point that
nobody's going to see this film if if we
can help it but and I remember at the
screening there was a lot of the people
from the international wailing
commission
meeting from Japan where there the
Whalers the the dolphin hunters were in
the back of the room and we had a uh a
night vision camera in in the the
theater and I remember the
previous um head of the IWC for Japan I
think he was educated in at Yale or or
Oxford you know Western educated and he
was expert at crafting as rebuttal about
the need to you know for Japan to still
do whaling in you know defense of the
the dwindling number of whales and I
remember this
when when the The Killing scene starts
in the Cove I remember looking at this
guy and he and he just he's looking at
the film and he just goes like this in
his seat he's cuz covers his hands with
his face with his hands and he's shaking
it like you know the world just changed
there's nothing you could do he just
knew there's nothing you could say about
that it's done that guy um the IWC the
international whaling commission these
governing bodies the MSC what is that
the Marine Safety Council commission
something like that
um are problematic I mean there's so
much corruption it's one thing to be
boots on the ground around Grassroots
activism um you know locality by
locality and try to you know coales a
movement out of that through film and
and you know other various means of of
raising awareness but at the from a top
down perspective you have these
governing bodies that are just I mean
just so patently on their face blatantly
corrupt in the scenes in the Cove where
we see that Japan is literally paying
these failing small developing bankrupt
Nations to vote you know in lock step
with them on these measures around
wailing and the dolphin trade it's just
it's so obvious to everybody and yet
despite being out in the open continues
to continues to happen and then I think
there was even even more recently with
the MSC and and whaling in Iceland Etc
like it's like can't we just all get
behind the fact that we shouldn't be
killing whales and dolphins I think
we're heading that way you know Iceland
I think is I think they're 2025 they
said it's going to be their last year
doing it I mean it is happening it
doesn't
happen as quickly as I would want but
I'm you know if they're killing one
dolphin for human consumption that's too
much but still when you you have to you
know take these victories that we have
and celebrate them because if you only
focus on the negative bits like the you
know the three countries that are still
doing it you know are you able to hold
on to that level of Hope and optimism I
mean the Cove came out in 2009 it's 2023
like when you look back how much
progress has been made what still you
know has yet to happen that maybe you
thought would have happened by now like
when you look at you know that world
yeah I guess the it's the Captivity
trade you would think that because
that's the economic engine that drives
that they're not killing them because
you know for $600 a dolphin it doesn't
pay for the gas uh they're they're doing
it for the captive dolphin industry and
You' think that once people you know in
over in Asia you know China Japan Middle
East if they saw you know I guess we
need a black fish another you know
another film about you know sort of
dolphin intelligence dolphin rights I
don't know I don't know how to cuz that
industry is booming in China and in the
Middle East as well yeah the Middle East
I I haven't followed in the last couple
years I know with the pandemic they were
failing but now maybe it's bounced back
even more MH I
mean we we certainly were part of a
group that got that you know we you know
we we got things moving in the right
direction on that I'm I'm on other
things right now I'm I'm thinking like
okay we this can work how do we use the
same story
telling chops on these other bigger
issues and and scale it so that you know
we can see serious progress on you know
Food Systems on health right and and
that's what I'm focused in right now and
that's that sort of was like a almost a
trial balloon to see to show that it
does work you know we have people
working on that still in our business
but it's like you know the other side of
is it it takes a lot of money to keep
these doors open you know we have you
know people need to get paid and how how
do you the the movie didn't make a lot
of money you know it's amazing yeah make
this movie The Cove the first movie
you've ever made you win the Oscar for
it and you didn't make any money you
made no money well you know we made
enough money to pay back some of the
debts that we had to to do it but it's
uh you know I I tell people that want to
get involved in a documentary the first
thing I lead with is if you intend to
make money off of investing in a
documentary you're better off taking
your money to Vegas cuz your odds are
better there uh but if you want to
change the world there's no better place
to come than yeah yeah it is it is the
most effective way to provoke change I
think and you know to to you know onward
to your second movie racing Extinction
which I think is a better movie um I
mean cinematically more beautiful uh and
obviously you learned a few things about
film making like it's it's very
compelling uh but I don't know that it
was seen as much as the Cove is that
true like that just feels like under the
radar a little bit more than the Cove 38
million people saw it the first day oh
wow yeah it was on Discovery discovery
which is the biggest Network in the
world at that time anyway they had
access to two and a half million two and
a half billion people they did something
on precedent in their history they they
released it on every channel they had
starting for a 24-hour period starting
in New Zealand and you know when the sun
came up they showed it all day long
until it came up in California and then
um I think 38 million people saw it
those first two days and you know so it
had a big push but then it fell off the
radar it's like they're like they have
400 films or just you know became part
of their content we just got it back
recently and it's hard to you know to
pump it back but 38 million was a good
number if those were paying customers oh
my God that would be like if we had $10
for every you know person that came
through the door you know our Focus has
never been about making money you know
it's like you know we run a nonprofit or
organization out there we're trying to
lose people's money but it was like I
don't want to like walk into a
convention and have to hide my head
because there's four investors that you
know I I told them that you're going to
double your money or whatever it's just
not our our goal so we try to find
people that are are mission driven and
that you know we can focus on making a
film you know the business model for
making a documentary is completely
broken now just let's say you have a
average Marvel film $100 million
probably more like $200 million
they're going to advertise it they have
to get everybody in the theater to come
on that those first weekend or two you
have to spend another 100 to 200 million
to get people to come to it and how are
you going to do that with a documentary
how can you compete no it's not worth it
it's not worth it and I also
think the streamers uh have shifted
Focus
away from documentaries particularly hot
button documentaries I've noticed
um Netflix being a place originally that
was this incredible home for New
documentaries birthing new filmmakers
and really putting that um mode of film
making like on the radar in a very
mainstream way and we saw this great
success of so many documentaries in the
early days of of Netflix but now I think
the streamers are so focused on new
subscribers all across the world in
areas like Saudi Arabia and China that
they're much more hesitant to on board a
documentary that might cause a political
headache no matter how good or high
quality the documentary is um I had um
Brian fogal on who did yeah who did
Icarus and then when he made the
dissident nobody would touch it he won
an Oscar for Netflix and they were like
we can't take this movie you know so
things have changed and so for someone
like yourself who ruffling feathers
who's trying to say have difficult
conversations um it feels like the
streaming ecosystem isn't as hospitable
as it once was which makes you know kind
of threading the needle even more
difficult yeah I'm actually doing a a a
series for Netflix right now on food
it's is a lot of hard issues and I've
finding that it it is working it's been
you know we've you've been working on
that for a long
time ever since yeah probably since
2016 you know they took I was trying to
raise the money independently MH went
the Netflix route and but it's turned
around in the last week and it's like
I'm really like excited and happy that
they're really going for it there
are pushing it's not it's not complete
control but I don't know if I'm you know
I I'm I'm a big fan of I don't want
to be the only one deciding what's going
to be out there I'm a you know we are
like I I like to to show to audiences
you know the I want a lot of control to
the writers The Producers the the
editors are certainly you know the ones
you know driving the ship at that point
and you give notes and and the notes are
coming back and part of it the reason
I'm like I'm not confident in this
process the first time
I've it's the second time I've done a
film where you never met you never met
the the editors like last week I was up
at everybody came to the office folks
from Netflix and the editors I meeting
him for the first time I've been working
on this thing for them for two years
I've never met them in the flesh and
usually I'm sitting literally every day
you know that we're editing I'm in the
editing room with an editor and now
we're giving notes and they come back
and a week later and you know and the
editor is the final author of the whole
thing I mean they have incredible
control over actually what it's going to
be yeah and they're you know they're a
little bit to be honest they're a little
bit more you know Netflix has Final Cut
and you know they're they're paying the
bills you know through us but they're
paying the bills so they're like you
know their allegiances to the the
streamer and luckily we have a a good
team at Netflix that's that's you
know I don't know if it did any good but
I did you know when I was in Indonesia
with a really limited you know bandwidth
a couple weeks ago and I just said
listen this is not why I'm in this
business you know we have to raise the
stakes every time I gave my you know as
a heart and speech as I can maybe it was
I found out later that they had already
implemented those changes but I'm like
in the middle of nowhere like literally
it's like without you know and I'm think
I'm seeing this cut and it t it took it
took me probably seven hours to watch a
a 45 minute cut of of an episode because
it just wasn't the bandwidth I had to
stay up late when nobody else is using
the system cuz we're with a small
satellite dish and I'm and I'm like
looking at this oh my God this is
horrible I'll never you know work in
this business again but it's just it
then when I saw the final one when I got
back to States side like I didn't have
to make that that talk they already they
already made the changes and they're St
it's back on the
rails but boy it's it's a different
world Co everybody's working from you
know they get conditioned to working
from home now and it's like nobody wants
to go back like to sit in in an office
and that's to me that's where a lot of
the magic happens you know it's like in
the field you're it's a a great creative
process you have wonderful DPS and
people that you're you know you're
you're up there doing at the work and
when you're not not in the room with
somebody it's different it's really
different I can't say it's better I I
miss it I I and I and who knows what
there's a lot of I mean there's there's
a lot of great things that happen when
you're in a room with somebody and
you're just having lunch and you're say
you know what about that scene can we
just try moving this over a little bit
and then if you have to explain it to
somebody or Worse explain it to like
with 15 other people on a zoom call it's
like it's just it's a laborious process
but it's changed it's it's the world
that we're living in yeah I feel like
it's moving back though I think that
rubber band is snapping back a little
bit um and you're right I mean there's
nothing there's no replacement for the
energy that this I don't I don't do Zoom
yeah this I am going to shorten the
table I get a lot of criticis we moved
it long like when coid happened and I
still wanted to do inperson
conversations and it stayed that way and
people like I can't believe how long
your table anyway that's a whole other
thing um yeah I get it uh but um I'm
glad to hear that is the is is is food
2.0 a series or is it just a documentary
it's a series it's a series right is
there a is there a what's the premiere
window for this be uh January of of this
coming year are you allowed to talk
about the subject matter that you
explore we can talk generally about food
and sustainable food generally you I
mean you know after the game changers uh
you know a lot of people saw that film
and that that film really you know first
of all I got to say that film had an
enormous um boost in the in the
community you know I'm told that ml
Lynch did a study last December not this
this previous one the one before and
they said that 75% of the worldwide
interest in plant-based diet is because
of that film it's unbelievable and it's
a credit to the entire team that that
made that film and Game Changers was
incredibly impactful it was exquisitly
rendered um and very meaningful not just
for the movement but for you know really
shifting people's opinions and
perspectives around diet particularly
for a lot of men who get caught up in
what they're eating and how that affects
their athletic performance to show a
very different reality in the most you
know palpable way that really has made
an incredible impact on culture you know
to your point of you know Weapons of
Mass instruction like it was
extraordinary I me it was really a
phenomenon when that movie came out and
uh I you know I I I couldn't be happier
that it made the impact that it that it
has made and continues to make I know
they're I think they just announced
they're gonna there's going to be a
second one I guess right right and I'm
not involved with it but yeah you know
more power to it but you know a lot of
people came out of that movie and they
said they would tell me just anecdotally
like oh I I was vegan what about now I
said well I did it for about three
months and fell off the wagon for
whatever reason I said why I said well
I'm not an
athlete and that's an extraordinary
statement like suddenly now this is the
this is the diet only for athletes like
that's quite a shift even though there
was a there was a Twist in that film
where you know James's father almost
dies of a heart attack and so we we it
does this whole other shift to like hey
this is not only good for athletes it's
good for you know you know civilians of
you know of normal eating to to eat this
way it's it's it's a good healthful way
but so in response to that I wanted to
do a film that you know it's called food
2.0 now this working title to be changed
to something else but um I mean the
premises of it is fairly simple I wanted
to address this idea people said oh I'm
northern European I'm black I'm this I'm
that my genetics are such that I I I
have to eat this way
so I thought well what if you gave
identical
twins
want a a healthy vegan diet I want a
healthy omnivore diet and then we
measured everything we possibly can you
know from the the usual stuff of blood
pressure cholesterol weight Etc but like
you know get into the epigenetics get
into you know this these new biological
markers that we didn't have the tools
with you know you know very well seven
years ago like microbiome yeah things
like that yeah and so we're working with
Stanford University and we have uh
identical twins where we had this very
are you working with the sonen felds I
am you are excellent yeah and and uh the
sh eyes oh nice weog testing and to me
it was like okay I don't know what the
results are going to be but and people
you know my my plant-based friends are
like well what what if it doesn't work
in your favor it's like well I'm
interested in the science I don't want
you know I want to I don't I want to
find out what's going on in our bodies
and so the if you take identical twins
you've taken out these variables right
if you have
uh it's like a almost a perfect genetic
test to to to see about the diet so so
and some of we're giving
a uh an athletic physical intervention
too so that we're you know we're testing
those as well but and I mean I I can't
tell the results but it was
uh it was fascinating and some of the
results
like the scientists over at Stanford
they were saying save your money you're
not going to see any anything happen in
8 weeks it's not a long enough time
frame and now I'm not going to tell you
the results but they've changed their
parameters for studies now based on that
one study is uh is Christopher Gardner
involved in that you got it yeah he was
here last week he yeah he was just here
last week yeah all com I just look at
your podcast and I just invited them all
to be in the movie glad I could help you
recruit all the people for your big TV
show um no that's amazing I'm I'm
looking forward to that how many
episodes four yeah yeah I'm I'm episode
four the the one of the new Cuts just
dropped you know as I was flying in this
morning so I'm really excited to see it
because that's like you know at the end
of the day I want people to to look
seriously at what they're putting in
their mouths there's there's no other
thing in the world that we can do to
give us agency over the environment over
personal health over the the welfare of
other creatures than what you put in
your mouth to me it's just like a it's a
brainer but but how do you make that
entertaining to people it's like you
know that's tough yeah you know you
don't want it to look like you know a
vegan propaganda yeah but you know I'm
I'm I'm thrilled with the the process so
far that you know we were really you
know I was sweating bullets for about
you know I'd say almost two years
thinking well what if this you know this
doesn't look good for you know I've
heard you've been talking about this for
a long time and I was interested in what
the status of it is I'll tell you
offline later okay yeah good um you know
to you mentioned you know how difficult
it is to you know sort of craft these
these challenging ideas around something
that's entertaining and palatable um and
it made me think of of the
recent uh Apple TV plus uh series
extrapolations did you have you watched
that I don't know about what is it it's
it's this limited series that tackles
climate change by C ing its gaze into
the future and every episode is like 10
years later as like you know this graph
of of carbon emissions continues to go
up and you kind of see the world the way
that it would appear during that period
of time and each episode is sort of a
standalone thing a lot of talented
people worked on this show it looks like
it was very expensive and the intentions
are nothing but you know extraordinary
but to me it ends up not really
connecting uh because it's it's trying
to be this important thing you know what
I mean and I think it is and I watched
it and I got a lot out of it but I think
there's a reason why you know someone
like yourself hasn't seen it or or maybe
a larger audience hasn't seen it because
it's missing that that piece around um
really connecting with an audience in a
in a very visceral emotional way I tell
other you know you know I'd say young
directors that you know you have a
choice do you want to be right or do you
want to effective cuz you know we're all
indignant about the way we think the
world should be but is that going to
connect is that going to work you know
is there what's what's the
audience that doesn't think the way that
you think going to how are they going to
connect with this are they going to see
it as propaganda are they going to think
of it as like is it entertaining you
know Michael Moore you know he said
first rule of filmm is don't be boring
and you could say oh well there's
nothing more important than saving the
world but like okay well you know I'm
very cognizant that you know you work
everybody works I'm assuming pretty hard
they're you know they're they're tired
they they get back from work and there's
it's like they have a choice what do you
watch on television do you want to watch
the new Marvel Star Wars thing which by
the way I watch too but like you know
what's going to what's going to make
them click you know so there's a word of
mouth that there's a scene in there that
um you know you got to see you know that
and and that's what I'm that's what I
think we do well I think I think
visually I'm I'm always like putting way
too much energy but valuable energy into
like how do you make this
scene give them something that they
haven't seen before at The Cove we we
put time-lapse Market you know
time-lapse cameras in the Market at ski
and you know it took us a month to we
had to get permission from all five of
the the major brands that controlled
that plus Mitsubishi which oversaw
everything so there's a lot of
negotiated back and forth that happened
to get those that one minute scene in
there but it's still probably one of the
best scenes about over fishing that I've
ever seen because it shows like this you
see the the gates open up you know the
and then you see the light come in the
tuna get out there you see the Smoke
Rise From the the frozen fish the the
buyers come in and they they take them
off and put them on the trucks it goes
dark happens the next day you see this
wave after wave of like oh my God these
are giant blue fin tuna that are now
endangered and they're just it's just a
commodity and you know it's just
something that's visceral yeah it's not
you could say that but when you see it
it does something else it clicks you
know um some writers can do that with
humor um Mark Twain talked about the the
Philippine War back in I think the you
know the turn of his Century the 1900s
and you know it's all the atrocities of
war that we thought about of Vietnam but
he's making us kind of
laugh at ourselves at our imperialistic
nature he's he there's there's a way
that you can communicate where people
can see themselves he did it through
humor I do it through a visual language
with the words and the music and you
know with a obviously with a big team of
very talented people more talented than
me but I'm the head bul Goose Looney
that wrangles them all together so that
we're all you know on a mission and then
we get us all in the room we're we're
thinking like is this I'm always
thinking like do we need those two
frames can we make this a little bit
shorter I'm feel I'm feeling like the
the audience a little bit hesitating can
we just make it speed up a little bit
can we and if you don't have those
assets in the field you're not going to
create them in the editing room and our
writer Mark Monroe has written four the
films I've done I said I said we have
the opposite problem that every other
filmmaker has we have too much good
stuff we have to kill a lot of our
babies they say you know stuff that we
love that we really worked hard to but
I'd rather have gone in the field and
gotten those asset assets and gotten
those stories so that when we we're in
the editing room we're surrounded by a
whole pallet of of beautiful scenes that
we can put together to orchestrate to so
we
can dial in that those emotional moments
so that we can find those hooks that'll
get people you know hopefully going from
one episode to the next and that's
exciting to me it's like you know but
you got to be doing it in the field you
have to be doing it from the creation
you're not going to be like you're not
going to find a you know a masterpiece
you know in the edit if you didn't shoot
it right or you didn't think about it
yeah in in racing Extinction it's
getting the Tesla and kiding it out
James Bond style with your team of
wizards who are like you know this Q who
are like you know creating all these you
know add-ons to that car to allow you to
project onto buildings and you know onto
clouds and all the like that becomes
this you know massive uh you know kind
of inflection point for popular
awareness yeah and it was it was it the
car was like a a transitional character
to get us to the big projections let me
explain that a little bit like you know
the people haven't seen the film we took
a a model as one of the early editions
like you said and made it into like a a
bond car for the environment it's the
first car in the world to have an
electroluminescent paint job we could
change the color of the car with a flick
of a button never been done before we
had a um forward looking infrared camera
Fleer camera that came out of the front
on a robotic arm so it could see the
invisible world of greenhouse gases out
of the back out of the hatch we had a
20,000 Lumen IMAX projector so we could
project those images on to skycrapers
are mountain tops we had disappearing
license plates that that whole thing and
it was you know was a it was a great
hook for that but what we were
interested in doing is the whole premise
of
that you know it started here actually
in La where at the beginning of the
movie AI Gill does these projections you
know he was at the sushi restaurant yeah
yeah so at the at the you know the the
Oscars and EMS it' be his screens that
they would rent you know the the like
high-end screens to you know for the the
the award ceremonies and he put one of
those he had the business that rended
those out to those places so he had a
screen that he put out in front of the
hump restaurant which was illegally
selling whale meet we busted our team uh
busted that restaurant essentially you
know and this this right during the
Oscars for The Cod too it was like I
remember there I didn't know that those
those time periods overlap oh my God it
was it was so funny because I didn't
even know the hump was in la oh yeah
it's at uh it was at the um Santa Monica
Airport they were selling all kinds of
endangered illegal fish and their Sushi
whale meat whale meat whale meat say
whales as the third largest whale in the
world so uh we had heard about it it
became like this sort of urban legend
and um we sent a couple of operatives
into the restaurant you know it's two we
were pretty because the The Cove was out
in theaters we hadn't yet won the the
Asar and but we were doing a lot of
press around town and stuff and you know
so we were kind of I want to say many
people would say oh you the person from
the movie what so we didn't want to go
in the sushi restaurant so Heather rally
and this other woman Crystal gbru they
went in um and we gave him like you know
some of the last money that we had to um
to do order a lot of expensive Saki and
you know in gratiate yourself to the
waiters and or to you know the whale
meet and we listening in the back of the
of a car you know these Transmissions
going on when they ordered
it so when we got the the story is when
we we got this this wh meet we had the
the samples and we went
to God I can't remember which agency it
was there like fish and wildlife there's
a couple different agencies that were
dealing with this and we took up took
the samples up to montere to Fish and
Wild I think it was fish and wildlife
and they said well that's all fine and
good but you need a chain of custody I
said what's that I said well we don't
know that you know one of our people
wasn't overseeing the sample uh it's say
well we had an analyze the say well but
you could have dis planted it so it' be
your word against them and they said can
you do a you know come with us on a bus
you know or get them to you know those
the same women and we'd run out of money
and they went and tried to do a sting
themselves but they couldn't get the
restaurant to sell them the meat and so
then when we were in La for the for the
Oscar Roundup um we were getting a comod
from the the mayor's office you know
some some award here in town and I I
remember looking at said like we got our
we got our team here we can go to we can
we can do this we can do the stin this
is this is like like two days before the
Oscar and there was actually a party
that night for at the mayor's Mansion or
wherever the mayor hangs out and
remember like my my wife at the time she
had like a you know we had a a you know
the distributor had like a limo and we
you know it was a big you know up event
and I said you go ahead without me I'm
going to go do this thing and she I
remember she I love her but she said why
don't you grow
up and I thought well this is what I I
was meant to do so who do you think I'm
married to oh bless her heart you I can
see it like it was you know this was
like a the one you know one night that
we could have
to can't you can't take a day off to go
to the Oscar you know s so this is I
can't Oscars are on a Sunday night we
did this like on a Frid Friday night or
Saturday night and we had these three
agencies agents at the bar at the sushi
bar our women went in with their you
know the same women two women Heather
and Crystal went in and they they did
the buy and then um and then I
remember we we won the Oscar on on
Sunday night on Monday morning it's like
front page news that you know we busted
the hump restaurant so it all happened
right at the same time it was like this
perfect and it wasn't just you know the
agency now here's what was going on we
had a I had a friend who was working at
the uh the the US uh IWC International
wailing commission meeting and he said
that at the time this might be
complicated but Obama who we all love
was making a back room deal with the
Japanese to give them open up um
commercial wailing in order to keep the
the bases open in okanawa that was the
rhetoric I heard and I thought we have
to press this because this deal is about
to happen so I want you know if it
became front page news that whale meat
is being sold right here in America we
could shut down those talks yeah it
would just that would become radioactive
for Obama so that's why we we we jumped
the gun so like we didn't wait for the
uh fish and wildlife and and US Customs
to go through you know what have they
had to do to do a a proper bus we just
announced it and that was you know that
was it and they were they were pissed
off at us but like to me it wasn't about
like them getting a Ates for doing the
bust it was about trying to shut down
this idea of opening up commercial
whaling again that was the reason for it
but that all happened at about the same
time it was yeah that's wild the
compression of of time on
that it's
so wild to think about the fact that
whaling still exists and that people are
hunting and killing dolphins these you
know magical
extraordinary incredibly uh uh you know
intelligent animals and if there was one
thing in that extrapolation series that
that kind of stuck with me there is a
sequence in which you know the oceans
are completely acidified and the whales
I think there's like you know maybe one
or two whales left but they have cracked
the code in in uh in deciphering the
language like they've they've got the
technology to do that so there's a
sequence where somebody is you know is
in a like in an underwater there's a
station and part of it's underwater and
they're you know communicating with this
with this whale and it made me think
about the potential with AI and how
quickly it's advancing right now in our
capacity to figure out uh the nuances of
how dolphins and whales you know and and
and other you know other of these
citations you know are are communicating
in a way that you know maybe we could
figure out yeah it was interesting like
I mentioned Roger Payne he's the he's
the
guy that discovered that humpback whales
are singing so back in the I think it
was the 70s he wrote a paper and you
know whales use rhyme they have meter
they have but they don't have a what
they don't have is a start and a in a
finish they have it's a river of song
like they'll have an 18-minute song but
they don't say okay and then start again
they'll keep on singing so this was
novel back in the 1970s and National iog
graphic came out with a record called
songs of the humpback whale was still
the largest single pressing of musical
recording ever done bigger than the
Beatles bigger than Elvis bigger than
Taylor Swift don't hold me to that but
it was anyway and uh that is what
sparked the save the whale movement and
that created that helped create the
moratorium for wailing and Roger just
died on Saturday and so he knew he was
going to die and so I called him up on
Thursday the last day before his full
day alive on the planet he just told him
what he meant to us you know how he how
he moved things forward and how much I
loved him when I had when I was working
on the cove and Jim had Athena he he
gave me that boat to use for one of some
of our first Expeditions and we went
down to Silver Banks which is where 80%
of the North Atlantic humpback whales
come to mate and give birth and to you
know socialize these five distinct pods
from the northern Atlantic come all down
to the silver Banks about 70 miles north
of the Dominican Republic and he Jim
said who do you want to invite and my
first guest was Roger Payne so a couple
friends of mine have their something
called their Earth species project where
they're using AI to try to decipher
language and said you got to meet Roger
Payne he's the guy that started it all
his wife Katie Payne was actually the
one who first figured it out and then he
wrote it up and you know they they
worked it out together but it was really
Katie and Katie by the way um his his
ex-wife is the one that discovered
that not only uh it whales use you know
are singing she's also one that
discovered that elephants use
infrasound uh sound below our level of
of hearing to communicate now this is
this is fasc didn't I didn't know okay
get this so Roger was amazing I spent a
week with him on this boat you know an
amazing boat but the the whole he would
put these hydrophones in the water as we
were eating at this really fine boat you
know three masted Schooner out in the
middle of the water and he and and
anywhere you put now imagine there's
thousands of whales there it's only the
males that sing and they they're singing
you know to probably the same way that
you know we sing you know to find mates
to you know get your tribe together and
you can hear these strange ethereal
songs as you as we're having dinner and
they're they're right below us there's
like this alien Universe singing right
below the boat and you know he would he
would tell us about like blue whales
blue whales you know most of their song
happens below our level of singing like
when I'm talking right now if you saw it
on an oscilloscope it'd be like these
little quick waves right my voice going
up and down each note but the blue
whales operate on a different metronome
than you and I do if you saw their song
it through through a computer screen it
looked like a straight line but that
straight line was really one of those
squiggles but it's like a kilometer long
because their notes one single note is
like a kilometer long wow so but you you
have to you have to speed it up and
compress it you you speed it up and it
sounds like bird song
and because it's low infrasound they use
something called the deep ocean Channel
where the the colder water at the bottom
these waves propagate at the bottom and
they bounce off the surface and they can
actually go on for thousands of miles so
these whales can communicate thousands
of miles one of um so one of the the
proteges of of Roger Payne was this guy
Chris Clark he was in racing Extinction
and he was brought in sosus is uh the
underwater surveillance system that the
Navy used is to detect submarines and
they they started opening it up to
scientists and they brought Chris in to
try to figure out what this this one uh
what they call biological was doing and
he you know because at first they
thought it was a submarine like a
Russian sub it would go off in One
Direction it was using the same
frequency to Ping that the submarines do
and it would go it' be noisy for like
six or seven minutes then it would stop
and it would be in a different direction
he goes well that's not a submarine
that's a fin whale and it's
feeding and they they he he realized
that sosus is this underwater string of
hydrophones that the Navy strung along
the Mid-Atlantic Ridge you know roughly
halfway between you know eastern coast
of America and Europe and that's to
detect you know boats every submarine
and boat has a different signature and
they could you know they had somehow uh
they would put on these filters to take
out the Biologicals and somehow this
whale head you know developed his song
so it was sing at the singing at the
same frequency as the sub the subs were
there so anyway he he he realized Chris
had realized that you know they had this
filter on and that if they took the
filter off he could see where song was
coming from all over the Atlantic Ocean
so they had him turn he asked him to
turn it off and now the way he describes
it it was a secret bunker off in norfol
or someplace over one of these bases and
it was like a basketball court size area
with people at three screen screens
remember this is like in the early 90s
where nobody had more than two screens
right and there's you know dozens of
people with headphones all listening for
Russian submarines now Chris asked them
on this big screen to turn off you know
off the filter to filters at the
Biologicals he said it lit up like a
Christmas tree for a few for a few
seconds then it blew the
computers he said the he realized that
the whole ocean is full of song that you
know wherever you know wherever he put
He Go you go to the Arctic and
everywhere he put in a hydrophone you
hear citations somewhere singing close
by or far away because actually
oxymoronic but animals can uh sound
travels about four and a half to five
times quicker underwater than it does on
land so you know and if use these low
waves low frequency waves you can
transfer you can see you know they'll
travel those great distances like
thousands of miles in fact Roger Payne
thinks that these that blue whales
evolve so they could actually hear
themselves clear around the world in the
deepest at the longest part like the
Southern Ocean where there's no land
mass they can actually hear you know
trans they can ostensibly hear
themselves over 9,000 miles of blue
whale that's insane it is well anyway
that's crazy and I mean just just to
know that completely changes your lens
on like how you think of an animal like
that oh there's a when we had Roger on
the boat I'm trying to remember the
story okay one of there's a researcher
this is this was this I think would be
you know
what we're talking about is like a
Rosetta Stone right like like AI is like
a Rosetta Stone where you had like the
ancient Greek and then you had the um
Egyptian hieroglyphs right I think that
wasn't that what was going on they had
basically it was a ledger basically in
ancient Greek and the hieroglyphs and it
was a way that they could figure out
okay triangulate like what does this
symbol mean to this word that we do know
I see so that's that was like a key that
AI says okay we don't need to know
anything about language we'll just use
these models that and somehow figure out
what these animals are saying based on
you know this this very complex
algorithm that we don't even know
but this one of the researchers I had
the
about with Roger he put hydrophones in
the water there's a guy Lou her Herman
from Hawaii he was teaching Dolphins
tricks two pairs of dolphins tricks and
you can you put your fingers together
and go together and then he you do like
a a circular gesture do a flip and Dolph
I'm told Will readily get this they'll
they'll do that near instantaneously to
get put fingers together you know flip
your fingers in a circle the Dolphins
will swim to the bottom of the Tank come
back up they'll do a flip and they'll
get their reward and then you know they
would do this so well he'd be like okay
what if we said together and he put go
like his hands spread apart you know
like like your mind said be creative so
together be creative he said now they
put a hydrophone in the the water but it
was only one hydrophone so they don't
know what's being said but the the the
Dolphins instantly went down to the
bottom tank did a a flip went back in
the water then they spit out water in at
the same time into the face of the the
researcher ah so I mean so they catched
a plot basically yeah and they agreed
upon that but somewhere in there in that
language in my mind would be like is
spit water at the researcher in his face
you know I mean you could have
deciphered so I would say use AI in a
situation where you know what's going on
rather than right to reverse engineer
like what was communicated and
understood yeah so like what what
they're doing right now these friends of
mine I put in touch with Roger Payne is
they they're looking at they're taking
all the data from Cornell University or
I think scripts people where they have
these hydrophones out in the water
working right now and they're trying to
use AI to decipher what what these
animals are saying but they're they run
into What's called the cocktail problem
like if this studio was full of dozens
of people and then you're trying to
isolate what people are saying it's
called the cocktail problem what about
if you just just have two animals in a
room and you have a hydrophone in each
one of them so you know what what's
being communicated that to me is like
but you know that's why I'm a you know
filmmaker not a researcher right right
right I mean I would
imagine that at some point they're going
to figure it out like these tools are so
powerful um it feels like it's only a
matter of time for the technology
advances enough and the the science
progresses where they're going to figure
this out and that could be like a
watershed moment in how we relate to you
know this underwater Kingdom that is so
poorly misunderstood and we you know
treat like the world's garbage can yeah
well imagine what you know if we could
well first of all you know a lot of
dolphin species and whale species have
bigger brains than us and they have the
dolphin brain is insane yeah and they
have more you know
convolutions of the gray matter so
there's more opportunities for you know
synapses for more you know they have
spindle neur neurons that are more
spindal neurons that associated with uh
processing complex emotions they got a
lot going on up there but you know we as
humans you know we keep on changing the
bar say well they don't use tools well
you know in fact crows you know chimps
and a lot of other animals do use tools
but you know we keep on saying you know
but they don't have computers but they
don't have podcasts you know it's like
we're never analyzing or valuing an
animal for how well it survives in its
environment and you look at like okay so
we have these big brains and sometimes
you can you know intelligence could be
how well does a
species work within the confines or the
the barriers of their own ecosystem or
do they try to impinge that you know if
you eat all you know if you consume all
the resources is that intelligence I you
know we're failing pretty miserably when
it comes to that metric yeah I think so
they're perfectly adapted to their
environment it's because they don't
um unlike humans they're not they're not
crafting their environment they're not
changing their environment yeah I
there's a i there's obviously there's
been a lot
of you know development over the last
four and a half billion years of human
history but I was talking to one
scientist and he said well you know the
Earth is going to be fine without us and
I said what do you mean he said well you
know let's you know the the Earth is
always changing you know the Advent of
blue green algae created oxygen and it
gave us us and a lot was a lot of
winners and losers when oxygen became
you know one of the you
know the chemicals in the atmosphere and
I said to him but Blu green algae didn't
have a choice you know we're at the cusp
of what they call the anthropos you know
the six ma major Extinction in the you
know on the planet there's been five of
them all caused by you know either
geologic or meteorological you know
issues asteroids and those are all
events that you know one species wasn't
in control of but we're we have a choice
unlike you know a wild animal and that's
what maybe is different about us and to
me the question becomes how quick can we
all figure that out so that we're making
choices that are you know good for the
environment you know and and so how do
you think about Solutions with this idea
you know humankind is the asteroid in
this equation in this you know Mass
species Extinction event that's there's
no what's that that's act one yeah
that's okay so we're in Act One um you
know I don't want to I don't want to
have to experience the bottom of act two
where Everything feels hopeless and
somehow at the last minute we figure out
how to solve this problem we have
solutions to pretty much all of these
problems it's the implementation of
these Solutions it's you know activating
you know a base of enough people to be
adopters of these Solutions and then
it's the top down you know political
will conversation around getting
everybody coralled into you know one
mindset around solving this problem well
or these this series of problems there's
some really good evidence in science
about shows that social change happens
when you have 10% of the population 100%
committed to the truth and that you know
that's you look that's what happened
with electric cars that's what happened
with with cell phones that what happened
you know the the suffragette movement
that's what happened with civil rights
movement and then like we said earlier
that's when you get to 30% that's when
people are doing it just because it's
been normalized I think
that TR trying to get this these
movements up to the 10% so that it's
Unstoppable is part of my job and that's
one reason by the way we do the
projection events you know when you know
films like you know
the films that we let's say racing
Extinction 38 million people the first
weekend the first
night that's great but that's not 700
million people which is you know or 800
million people which is 10% of the
population of the planet that's why we
do the projection events with the
projection events we found and and and I
knew this at the point from Lani moter
she said she's the one that you know
showed me these first studies and I I I
read the study and I called up the lead
researcher because there was three pages
of algorithms some math that I just
didn't understand it was never in my
strong suit and I said to him can you
give this to me in Lay language what
this means what this paper means because
I understand what 10% of the population
means 100% but I don't you know
understand the why of all this math he
said well it's like if you're trying to
create steam it'll never happen unless
you get water up to a boiling point he
said 10% of the population 100%
committed is the boiling point for the
exchange of social ideas and that I can
understand it's like okay if but how do
you reach 7 or 800 million people with
the projection events we can do it when
we when we did racing Extinction we
showed it at Sundance we at that point
we we had only projected on the United
Nations and it looked good it looked
beautiful um you know the the front of
the UN by the way this was done with
permission with the UN with Bon kimon
who was working on the uh 2014 this was
the preamble to the uh the Paras cords
mhm and it looked good but the the New
York police said they would shut us down
if we had over 2,000 people attend cuz
they were worried about 600,000
activists in town and them story in the
gates whatever fantasy they had in their
heads so it never had that kind of
momentum that that I wanted what I'd
always wanted to do was to project on
the Empire State Building because I
thought that was like you know to me
there's something symbolic about it the
un's great but if it without a crowd it
didn't it was never going to resonate
and remember discovery at that point
they you know they paid us all the money
they were going to give us it was going
to cost like you know $1.5 million to do
a projection event and they said the
film's good enough don't worry about it
and I thought well we need to get a lot
of people to see it otherwise it'll just
be like it just be another good movie
you know that wasn't my objective how do
you change things so um they said well
if a projection event in August in New
York said all the important people are
going to be in the Hamptons they're
going to be over in you know over in
Europe it'll be a non-event it'll gets
dark late New York and not so the Press
won't be there they can't afford to pay
overtime it'll be a non-event and so we
did it I raised the money we did the
event I remember we had rented out a bar
uh overlooking the Empire State Building
and my son came up for it and he goes
dad there's people in the streets and I
thought he meant people on the streets
waiting to get into the the bar because
it was it was packed and he he goes no
no look over the side of the building
building we looked over in like Fifth
Avenue with all these projections going
off and dangerous species on the Empire
State Building it was like the the the
New York Easter Parade it was just like
you know packed you know like traffic
was you know was halted so I went down
to take a look and you know they they
couldn't hear the music they didn't know
what was going on up there they just saw
something extraordinary and they all had
phones they all had you know everybody
became a photographer and um we had some
media show up but like the cops said hey
if this get too crazy we're going to
have to shut it down but we it took me
four years to get permission from the
city to do those projections and we had
939 million media views by Thursday it
was the top trending story on Facebook
and Twitter for four days worldwide wow
and we thought you know it was on the
cover of like you know the New York
Times it was you know all the media
everybody picked up on it and everybody
had a cell phone and that it got shared
a lot we did so yeah billions and
billions of eyeballs on us and then so
we uh we thought we couldn't get any
more attention to the subject than that
of endangered species you know in the
anthropos and then the pope
calls and the pope wanted us to project
on the Vatican for his lado sea this was
in December while world leaders were
meeting in Paris to talk about their
chords you know because remember Pope
Pope Francis is named after St Francis
the patron saint of animals animals yeah
so we did a projection event there and
it was so surreal because we're think
like we we didn't meet with the Pope but
we met with his number two over at the
Vatican previous you know when we we get
the job to go do it and he goes to me
I'm not going to be able to repeat his
his accent but he goes if it was up to
me I this wouldn't happen and I said why
and he says well because the last artist
to do anything on the Vatican was
[Laughter]
Michelangelo and so we had there was 600
media there we had you know that whole
Square leading up to the you know the
Vatican was filled I think 225,000
people saw it live uh we had 4.4 billion
media Impressions just in the English
language and you know it it at least in
America those projections help create
laws that prevent some of the most
endangered species from being trafficked
on you know through US ports which was
there was a loophole that they were
getting through so that and and to me
like we have another uh projection event
that we're we'll find out what's going
to happen tomorrow but um we're working
on with the Empire State Building again
in the city of New York who now wants us
to come back and we want it to be all
like three nights projection one on food
one on solutions to climate change and
we know that we've reached nearly a
billion people before with a three-day
night with a three night projection
we'll be able to build on that so for me
this a way to scale change it like a
movie is great it's it's powerful but a
projection event is a way to cut through
all the the media hype you don't have to
pay for this either instead of like you
know getting you know paying for
advertising you're getting people that
want to share it that that's kind of the
it's super powerful and the Artistry
that goes into these projections like I
don't know how you find these artists to
kind of craft these displays but they're
they're really Exquisite oh thanks
thanks it is you know it is you know
we've got a lot of college you should be
going you should be I mean talk about
scaling social change I mean you could
just have projection events going on all
over the world all the time that's the
idea because everybody has what we've
learned about projections like you can
pull up to I don't know a building and
La that's kind of dark and project on it
but like so what you know I mean the
there's there has to be some sort of
symbolic meeting meaning behind it so
when you project on the United Nations
it's like this is the one building that
represents the world coming together to
look at big existential problems and
solutions the Empire State Building
represents the Pinnacle of you know City
Life and progress and you know
capitalism and then when you put animals
on it it's sort of vibrates against that
what that means you know I mean you're
saying this is important too this is
nature you don't see it in the city and
now you're seeing the kids are like they
didn't know what these animals were
they'd never seen them before and you
forget that if you live in a city your
exposure to Nature is really limited by
like what you see on TV or maybe up in
the Adera or something but you don't get
to see like you know a Golden Lion
Tamarind or you know any of these
creatures so they all look like alien
creatures so right uh um I want to talk
to you a little bit about uh you know
Legacy how you think about you know the
meaning that you're that you're leaving
behind Etc uh but I want to do that
first I want to preface that by asking
you a little bit about this um project
that you did uh around Joy with Desmond
Tutu and and and the dolly llama I have
not yet seen that that film um but I did
read the book and and Doug Abrams is a
very good friend of mine we went to
college together and he's been on the
podcast
twice so I mean Doug and I I've known
Doug since I was 18 really yeah oh Doug
so how did you get involved with that
and talk to me a little bit about that
and and also how it's kind of maybe
changed maybe it hasn't changed but I I
I would venture to imagine that it
probably has kind of changed how you
think about you know your work and your
life yeah everything really I mean I was
at a I was down in San Jose where Doug
lives and I was at a dinner with a lot
of other people and sitting a room full
of really interesting people and then
halfway through the host said oh now to
mix it up switch with other people on
their side of the room I found myself
sitting next to Doug and I said I didn't
know him I didn't go to school with him
I said what do you do he said well I'm a
I'm a a book publisher I said well
anything I would have heard of he said
well I'm probably best known for the
book of Joy I said I love that book
that's amazing what do you do I said
well I'm a
filmmaker you know what have you done I
said the cove and I don't know if you
even heard of it and then he he
mentioned that they
had documented that meeting between
Desmond Tutu and and his Holiness the
Dal Lama and he said said well we have
like like 18 hours of footage over a 4
and a half day period do you think it
could be made into a film I said well
let's take a look at it so I saw it in
the raw form and I found myself as I was
watching it like having all these light
bulb moments in my head about Joy like
what you know really figuring I know
this podcast is full of now a lot of
great people talking about what gives
you Joy but what really resonated for me
was like yeah of course that's why I
feel good when I do something that's not
just for myself when it's for others
it's it does feel good it's what they
call you know like a wise selfish you
know when you're doing something good
for you it also feels good for me and
that's okay it's like fully selfish is
when you're doing it only to get
something out of somebody it's
transaction or it's like it's one-sided
and that did make me feel like God I
wish I would have seen that that a film
like that like you know when I was in my
20s and so this is before the pandemic
and I said yeah I think we can you know
cut footage you know we'll have to go
back and you know re-engineer some of
the stuff and you know film scenes with
the doy Lama and Desmond 2u and then the
you know Co hit and now now all of a
sudden trying to make a film like where
you're afraid to go out of the country
or you can't get into the country and
like I mentioned before like you know I
made that film with people who I never
even met physically I met Doug CU he was
right down the you know down the street
so to speak you know in California but
that film was like uh so important to me
you know in my head like you can't
change society unless unless they you
figure out a way that you can
communicate with them like you can you
can understand people and what does give
them joy and to me that film was like a
I'd call it like chiropracty for the
soul you know just everything snapped
into place for me like okay this is you
know how do you take you know one of the
big takeaways from the that film to me
was like you have these two spiritual
leaders two of the greatest spiritual
leaders in the world probably at that
point at this point still how do how do
you you know what do they have in common
you know the Dal Lama thousand room
Palace you know with you know servants
and you know could lead an army and you
have Desmond Tutu born in the squalor of
you know the slums of South Africa but
they both learned that out of this kind
of grief is probably only possible to to
get really great joy you know you have
to take a hardship and turn it like
what's how can you turn this around
what's where's the Silver Lining and CU
there's always a way to reframe it you
know that's kind of a classic Buddhist
thing is reframing you know instead of
what was me like okay how do you turn
that negative bit I mean like look at
your own Journey you know you took you
know being overweight and alcoholic and
doing drugs into you know one of the
most popular podcasts in the world you
know it's a with without that you
probably wouldn't be here no yeah no
there's no question about it um but
finding that way to um you know channel
that
pain um to you know first of all heal
yourself but then uh figuring out a way
to to to give it back or to you know be
of service um and tying that you know
somehow to things that you care about or
problems that are greater than you in
the world is to my mind like the Holy
Grail like if you can find something
that you love uh that's also meaningful
for other people and is solution-based
for some of the problems that we face as
individuals and as a collective there's
nothing more fulfilling in my life and
certainly you know you're you're living
your life in that in that
manner yeah I think I
mean but the takeaway from from all that
was like God there's like there's
there's the joy sorry go ahead yeah no
that's just it that that's the the joy
that when you think about the moments
that really give you Joy that like
lasting Joy they talk a lot about that
in the film is like you know what kind
of Joy are we talking about and you know
it's not like a permanent state of
Utopia it's just those hits that you
have when you're know on the right path
when you are giving back when you are in
service to the universe rather than just
yourself um and then if you can just
align yourself with this you know you
know only bringing the people in that
you want to talk to or just you know
narrowing in on the focus of like what
what we all have a limited amount of
time on this planet and like how you
decide to use those and who you decide
to to share them with is probably the
biggest decision that we can make right
you know and
um and and making that your North Star
making that my North Star is certainly
given me the the more fulfillment that I
ever knew was possible in fact that's
why Jim Clark I say has made me the
richest person in the world because he
did give me the opportunity to do to
find that North Star that I don't think
I would have had without him yeah that's
beautiful I mean I think on top of that
the joy provides a more sustainable fuel
source to to kind of pursue what it is
that you care about long term and I
think what you see in the activist
community in particular is is you know a
very
shortterm uh fuel source based on you
know being upset with the state of the
world and feeling like any self-care or
experience of Joy would be an Indulgence
because it's so dire and it requires all
of your attention and as a result a lot
of people burn out or they just can't
they can't maintain that level of
intensity in the work that they're that
they're doing um but to kind of disabuse
people of the idea that that you know
it's okay to experience joy in the midst
of all of this and in fact if you can do
that it it sets you up to be an even
better servant in the short term and
gives you the ability to serve long term
well said it's hard though yeah hard
well I mean I think if you're on the
path though I mean you you you know when
you can when you you do have you're
pointed towards that North Star and you
start to Veer off you know it yeah you
know you you you know I Veer off a lot
I'm a grouchy resentful
[Laughter]
[Music]
um I got to let you go but like you got
you have a lot of stuff you're working
on right so you have this food 2.0 Show
on Netflix that's coming up we talked
about um but you also have uh this um
she change project with the with the
female big wave Surfers right which
sounds pretty cool a great one four kick
ass wom Surfers I got pay parody in the
sport of you know male Domin sport of
big wave surfing yeah that's a great
film it's hard you know for some reason
it's hard to get funded too I mean we're
still struggling for that last million
but I think it's such a great film it's
not just about surfing it's about
women's it's about pay Equity right yeah
pay Equity it's about women's rights you
know it's there there's that story we're
working on a film on you know um the
great filter and uh the fmy Paradox you
know about that uh that's the the the
fmy Paradox is that the if there's
aliens where are they and the great
filter is maybe maybe it's the DNA of
life forms in the universe that they
burn out of the resources before they
have a chance to be able to communicate
or travel great distances interesting
yeah and then um doing a film on plastic
pollution Solutions that's come a long
ways that's a great one whole podcast on
that yeah I saw that that was great yeah
and is that all of these are in
different stages of production and
development yeah i' say well we're done
filming the food 2.0 the the uh we're
about I'd say half done with the
Plastics film I have a co-director of
people wonder like how can you do all
this just like I have a lot of great
people that I work with um she changed
I'm just an executive producer you know
helping put the team together and raise
the money um I'm doing a book project on
still with that camera you know that
Clark built for us we just got back from
Indonesia we're there for about two and
a half weeks it we won't have to go on a
big tangent but boy it's like you know
we went to the the the place on the
planet where you can see the most fish
on a single dive you go to the Caribbean
you're lucking to see 30 fish on a dive
you can see three 00 down in this place
called Rajan Western Papa guini owned by
um Indonesia iria and it's like 76% of
the world's corals hard corals are found
there so and soft corals um it's one of
one of the dive guys said when when God
said let there be fishes this is where
he was standing it's like it's just like
The Land Before Time and it's really
hard to get to and you know we dive with
rebreathers so we can stay down for like
2 and a half three hours at a time if we
need to um
it's a big video production you know
with lights and cameras but underwater
and then you can kind of wait for these
tides to change so you have this
upwelling of Plankton and the soft
corals Bloom and the fish come out and
it's really kind of amazing and with
this camera you can see far more with
your eye then you can with when you're
actually there it's just you come back
with these these these images and it's
just extraordinary beautiful and part of
it is to get a Bas line so you know even
that that place is starting to get hit
by bleaching and you know global warming
you know just a two de shift in an
increase in temperatures and you lose
the world's corals so we're at that cusp
and you know we want to see a baseline
of like how beautiful was it cuz you
know the Next Generation might not know
what they lost because you know we're
losing it and I want to go to I want to
create a big book book like a Sumo siiz
book on you know using this
extraordinary camera to see something
that people haven't seen before wow and
yeah we have a couple projects going on
you know but but uh it's like I just
love doing what we're doing cuz it's
like I mean I kind of wish I would have
been doing this when I was 20s in my 20s
but then somebody said well you probably
would have made shitty movies when you
were in your
20s um I don't know about that I mean I
think uh it's cool that I mean how old
were you when you made the Cove were you
in your 50s yeah Late Bloomer There's
Hope for all of us out there like first
movie in your 50s you win the Oscar um
but but I also think there's interesting
new avenues of creation that are that
are becoming available to help tell
these stories and impact people like I'm
I was thinking of of Michael Mueller the
photographer turn filmmaker and what
he's doing with VR with sharks and you
know being able to you know give a kid
in a village a headset and have him feel
like he's underwater swimming with the
sharks easily you could do that with the
coral reefs and any number of these
other you know kind of endangered areas
that give people that that real you know
strong emotional connection yeah we're
we're working on that we're looking at
uh you know new capture techniques in
fact I'm going up on Saturday to look at
some people up at you know up in the
where people think big up in Boston to
to work on a project that we could you
know to me it's all about scale you know
it's that um how do you how do you
affect people quick with the the amount
of change that we need and VR seems to
be a good way to do it because it's more
immersive it's more emotional you maybe
you don't need 30 minutes or an hour and
30 minutes maybe you can do it in 20
minutes one of the problems I have with
VR is it's hard to you know it's usually
a one-off it's like you know you need a
set of goggles you're not seeing it in a
group there's something that's
transformative when you're seeing um a
movie with other people sure of course
yeah there is it's still it's not quite
there yet I get a little seasick wearing
the thing and you know yeah it's it's
going to happen at some point well I
really love the work that you do I think
that you are you know a really important
voice in this movement for so many
reasons and uh you know the movies that
you've made have just been incredibly
impactful to me personally and to
millions of people across the world and
I can't wait to see what you create next
and I'd love to have you back when food
2.0 comes out or the plastic you know I
could do I would love to talk to you
about the plastic problem I'm afraid to
even ask one question because it'll be
two hours but uh yeah you're you're uh I
mean you're I just I have so much
respect for what you do and and more
importantly like the way that you do it
the intentionality that you bring to
your projects and and just the manner in
which you you comport yourself as a
steward of the planet and an activist
and uh you know a creative voice so
thank you for sharing well thanks for
the AL but again I got to say it's a a
team effort you know it's like everybody
involved is like a you know it's a
process it's like you know I get too
much attention to what we do when it's
really a team but yeah I appreciate it
thank you so much and I love the podcast
it's like it's my go-to when I you know
on a car you know it comes on
automatically as soon as I open the car
door you start I start hearing your
voice all right thanks man I appreciate
that
cheers that's it for today thank you for
listening I truly hope you enjoyed the
conversation to learn more about today's
guest including links and resources
related to everything discussed today
visit the episode page at Rich roll.com
where you can find the entire podcast
archive as well as podcast merch my
books Finding Ultra voicing change and
the plant power way as well as the plant
power meal planner at meals. ral.com if
you'd like to support the podcast the
easiest and most impactful thing you can
do is to subscribe to the show on Apple
podcasts on Spotify and on YouTube and
leave a review and or comment supporting
the sponsors who support the show is
also important and appreciated and
sharing the show or your favorite
episode with friends or on social media
is of course awesome and very helpful
and finally for podcast updates special
offers on books the meal planner and
other subjects please subscribe to our
newsletter which you can find on the
footer of any page at Rich roll.com
Today's show was produced and engineered
by Jason ciolo with additional audio
engineering by Kale Curtis the video
edition of the podcast was created by
Blake Curtis with assistance by our
creative director Dan Drake portraits by
Davey Greenberg graphic and social media
assets courtesy of Daniel CIS thank you
Georgia Wy for copywriting and website
management and of course our theme music
was created by Tyler Patt traper Patt
and Harry mathys appreciate the love
love the support see you back here soon
peace plants
namaste
[Music]
every